Ben Travis gentlemen congratulations you
have now made it into the third and
final round of this competition where
you're going back to your home forges
for 4 days to build an iconic weapon
from history gentlemen you're going to
be building
this the Crusaders Bible falion good
luck we will see you both in 4 days
let's do it all right right
on this is going to be my inner core
this
5160 and then we're going to do Damascus
on the outside
I'm doing Damascus with a sanm inner
core because I think if I keep a 5160
leaf spring steel core it will hopefully
stand up and be resilient to the judge's
tests so in the Forge they got big blue
I have little orange it's like taking
big
blue actually it's nothing like taking
big blue it's it's a little
guy it's 5 tons but it sure as heck
saving my shoulder and my arm get this
thing in the Forge and I'm going to
start drawing this out I'm getting to to
a point where I'm going to try to create
this handle I basically have to make a
candy cane or a horseshoe start putting
a curve in I overcompensated and kind of
had it come in a little closer than I
thought so as I strike here it's going
to push this around and flatten it out a
little bit the curl for the handle it's
not perfect I am a little concerned
about the ergonomics of this I want to
keep myself on the forward progression
that I'm in right
now I pull it out
and we are straight I'm going to focus
on the handle the maple that I have is
pretty hard I did not know it was going
to be this much of a challenge I put a
lot of heart and soul into this I think
I'm good with my blade I want to hear
Doug say those three little words it
will
kill I plan on making sanm 5160 leaf
spring Salvage from a semi- trailer and
I'll Forge that flat and square and then
my shells are coming from rot iron Wagon
Wheel the rot iron should have a very
pretty wood grain look by the time I get
it ground down and net so far it seems
like my Billet is welded tight and
everything's holding up I just hope my
luck carries through I'm using a
fullering tool and I'm hammering my
Billet I've got my blade mostly to shape
and profile it's about time that I start
moving on to heat
treat then I pull it out to inspect it
my lines are looking okay just by nature
of me flying by the seat of my pants
feel like I'm behind schedule but I'm
hoping I can just pull something out and
make it
work decided to just use a a rasp to
shape my uh wood because it's the only
tool that's going to fit in there in a
timely manner I've got my blade finished
now it's time to get an edge on this
thing I still feel that it's 50/50 but I
think I was able to make a pretty blade
and I'm satisfied with what I got
accomplished blad Smiths welcome to the
kill test Ben you're up first you ready
for this I'm not but I hope my blade is
all right let's do
it
all right Ben let's talk about your
weapon here what I like about the handle
it's aoid enough to where it fits my
hand perfectly your Edge is sharp and it
chopped this pig not once but twice
overall your weapon it will
kill Travis your turn sir are you ready
R I'm never going to be all right let's
do this
all right Travis let's talk about your
weapon here first stop I appreciate the
pattern you have with your Damascus your
handle has a cylindrical feel to it it's
very smooth and because it's a forward
heavy blade it rides back here there is
nothing for me to be able to get a good
retention so every strike I had to
adjust a couple of times but your Edge
is sharp it chops deep and as you can
see it chop the big carcass in half
overall your weapon you'll kill thank
you
Dad blad Smith welcome to the strength
test the Pavilion pole
chop not only did we get the crazy shape
of your fions out of the Crusader Bible
we also found this test in there there's
a scene in the Bible where Abraham's
forces are chopping down the tent poles
of their enemies so we're going to do
the same thing and see how your fions
hold up then you're up first you ready
as right as I can be all righty
well Ben first off that's a beautiful
piece I mean it really captures the
essence of of what's in the crusador
Bible the the handle is really well uh
proportioned for my hand I'm just
touching the hook while I have a
comfortable grip on the rest of the
handle so nice job The Edge held up
great all in all I think it's a a
spectacular piece nice job thank you all
right Travis you're up man you ready no
let's do
it
all right Travis well your Edge held up
great that being said the handle it's
really long and it kind of Curves from
the beginning so as I'm trying to hold
up here you know I'm sliding back and
when I close my eyes and index exactly
where I want to be it's kicked over by
about five degrees so I had to
compensate for that that being said I
really think you you did a great job of
of capturing the spirit of this
particular falion nice job I appreciate
it thank
you all right blad Smiths this is
sharpness test the zipline sandbag
slice then you're up first you ready for
this sure all right let's do
this
all right Ben let's talk about your
weapon on the different areas that you
have especially on that sweet spot it
cut cleanly on the bag on the lower half
over here met a little resistance but it
also cut overall your weapon you will
cut I'll take it all right Travis it's
your turn are you ready oh I'm ready all
right let's do
this all right Travis again cutting with
this on The Sweet Spot it cut cleanly on
both bags go a bit lower on this section
right here it cuts but not all the way
through overall your weapon sir it will
cut it thank
you well well well all right gentlemen I
got to say that this is the kind of
competition we love to see here in
Fortune fire at the end of the day only
one of you guys can leave here with the
title of Fortune fire champion and get
that check for $10,000 today's force and
fire Champion
is
Ben
congratulations Travis I hope you had as
much fun as we had watching you in the
first two rounds we want to say thank
you for coming out but unfortunately
your time in this competition has ended
I'm going to have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor thank
you
awesome well Ben congratulations that
makes you a forge of fire Champion
you'll be receiving a check for $10,000
congratulations thank you all right I
did not at all expect that I would make
it to the end but here we are every step
of the way of this process there's been
some sort of challenge or hiccup that
I've had to deal with but I'm just so
grateful I got the opportunity and I won
so I'm happier than I could ever
[Music]
be